- I really don't know what that means.
I don't know what any of these mean.
OK.
Cuz I never said thirst trap.
I wanna thirst trap, but
I didn't know what that is.
♪♪♪
[Glass breaking sound effect]
What's up, B/R? Phil Mickelson here.
I've played golf for a long time and kind of
proven that, uh, I'm OK on the golf course.
And now I'm working on developing
my social media skills.
So how am I doing?
And how can I get better?
You're the quarterback of a football
team playing in the Super Bowl.
A team from New York has just defeated
you, and a photo is taken of you sitting
on the field with your head facing down.
People begin to recreate your photo and
post to Twitter with different captions.
You have officially become a meme.
Actually knew that one. Wow.
Phil, that's me, says
he wants to thirst-trap
and posts a photo of his—my—calves on
Instagram with the caption, "Felt cute,
might delete later.
Hashtag Friday feeling."
What is a thirst trap?
Well, first of all, there's
nothing cute about my calves.
And second, why would I wanna delete it?
Who knows?
[Slow saxophone]
What is a burner account and which
of the four Match participants is
most likely to have a burner account?
A burner account is an account where
you can go onto social media and
people won't know that it's you.
And I think we're all pretty likely to have
one of those because...we'd like to have a
little bit of privacy on social media and
not have people know that it's us. But,
uh, Kevin Durant would be the most likely.
It was Durant that got
caught doing that, right?
Is that right?
- [Offscreen:] Yeah.
- OK, cool.